- [Together] Three, two, one. Blastoff!
- I Draw, You Cook is back.
- It's gonna be fun, it's gonna be good.
(hands slap, eggs crack, hammer bangs)
(Rie and Alix yelp)
(Katie hisses)
- Oh my!
- Little nervous, a little worried.
- I don't bake whatsoever.
- The judges are kids,
so I know my audience.
- [Katie] Nice to meet you.
- Have you eaten a star before?
- Yes.
- Oh, you did!
- So what is magical water look like?
- Colorful.
- Way out of my comfort zone.
- [Alix] Gonna take some risks today.
- Things could go wrong.
And I'm feeling so much
pressure right now.
- I'm scared.
- [Katie] Here we go. Here goes nothing.
(baking pan plopping down)
(dough dropping)
- Dude!
- I have a secret ingredient.
- Secret ingredient.
- I've never used one of these before.
It's always a great thing to say.
- It's looking good.
- You think that looks good?
Look at that.
- That looks radioactive.
- Hope this was a good idea.
(dramatic music)
- [Together] Roar!
- Let's go.
- Let's do it.
- What the!
- May the best astronaut win.
(music fades)